ladies and gentlemen boys and girls
welcome back to versus where today we
give an
extra special shout out to all you
residents of haddonfield illinois
the only town in america that zooms
right from labor day
into thanksgiving oh sure they used to
do fun fall activities like
trick-or-treating and
dressing up in costume but that was
before a guy named michael myers decided
to take his door-to-door shenanigans to
the next level
and ruin halloween forevermore the
legacy of halloween dates back to olden
times
and nowadays you'll see that holiday
reference and everything from
trick-or-treat to pumpkinhead but only
one franchise
has earned the right to name itself
simply halloween
and no i'm not talking about your tv
special garfield
cue the music
[Music]
while the original 1978 halloween still
holds up as a cultural touchstone that
inspired independent filmmaking
revolutionized the modern horror movie
genre and scared the crap
out of us today's battle is between two
of the franchise's most celebrated
sequels reboots reboot quote
yeah reboot quote that's the ticket
1998's h2o is taking on 2018's halloween
the 20th anniversary film versus the
40th anniversary movie
jamie lee curtis is back michael is here
and these two fantastically frightful
flicks are ready to duke it out for
silver metal supremacy
here's how we'll determine a winner
round one
box office round two tomato meter slash
audience score round three storyline
and then i'll do a wild card round to
seal the deal as to which movie truly
deserves to be on your shelf
right next to john carpenter's original
classic
buckle your seat belts haddonfield
residents this vid will take us all the
way to sunny california
and then back to the midwest and we
ain't stopping for pumpkin spice lattes
let's get it on do you know that i
pray every night that he would escape
what the hell do you do that for so i
can kill him
round one box office it seems like every
october that doesn't involve a global
pandemic
audiences look forward to flooding their
movie theater to scream
giggle and shriek at horror movies and
while no film in the halloween canon has
matched the domestic box office hall of
the 1978 classic
2018's version gave it a good run for
its literal money
sealing itself is the second highest
grossing flick in the series
h4o earned 165 million dollars on a tiny
budget under 10 million dollars
that was more than good enough to
instantly greenlight two sequels
halloween kills
and halloween ends ooh what's going to
happen in that one
we get halloween kills in october of
2021.
it's almost like michael myers just
won't go away
what's up
but that wasn't always the popular
sentiment in the 1990s
newer horror franchises like a nightmare
in elm street friday the 13th and scream
began to rule the horror movie landscape
after a handful of films all featuring
that classic holiday name all saw
diminishing returns at the cineplex it
appeared as though michael myers
lumbering stride had turned into a
retirement home shuffle
oh [ __ ] but then h2o began production
with big news
jamie lee curtis would be returning to
the franchise and reprising her role as
laurie strode
despite this great news her evil bro
mike still kept trying to murder her
dude don't you like money she's the meal
ticket
who was that
my brother h2o was a giant shot in the
arm for the dwindling halloween box
office from films like the revenge of
michael myers and the curse of michael
myers
and scored an impressive 110 million
dollar domestic haul
why i'm tempted to give that smaller
number the win in round one
is because halloween movies hadn't gone
anywhere yet the curse of michael myers
was released just three years prior
and despite netflix 32 million dollar
total take
we all showed up for the big anniversary
but according to our expert mathletes
here at rotten tomatoes h2o still
trails 2018's halloween by 55 million
bucks
and when we adjust the budgets for
inflation h2o costs 23 million dollars
more to make than our most recent flick
that kiddies is what we call
profit margin h4o did it the best at the
bo since 1978 and as a result gets the
win in round one
speaking of bo you could probably smell
michael coming from a mile away at this
point right
what are we gonna do cancel halloween
round two tomato meter slash audience
score
sure we all know and love the original
halloween so did critics as indicated by
its 96 percent fresh on the tomato meter
that's great for any flick especially a
horror one
but not all the films in the franchise
have had such a clean smelling scent
in fact h2o's immediate predecessor the
curse of michael myers was a serious low
point
earning just a nine percent which makes
it all the more laudable that h2o
climbed out of the seller and made it on
the brink of fresh
at 52 percent however despite fan
favorite jamie lee curtis returning to
her iconic role
the film scored lower on the audience
side of things at just 49
good for just the sixth highest audience
scorer in the entire canon
needless to say the door is open for
halloween the 2018 version
to take this round and if you've ever
seen any scary movie
you really shouldn't leave the doors
open it's the third dumbest thing you
can do besides
showering and losing your virginity i
did one of those today
you wanna guess which one
no fan and critic appetites alike were
salivating over the prospect of a new
team headed by david gordon green and
danny mcbride overseeing a rebirth of
halloween lore
and in 2018 it appears both got what
they wished for
the audience score of h4o was the second
highest in franchise history
earning a fresh 70 the tomato meter
features even better smelling veggies at
79 percent that's whole foods fresh
and once again is good for second
all-time amongst halloween movies
michael myers did just come back dude
brought some solid tomato offerings with
him
i'm a fan of both films and i love
getting the cinematic crap scared out of
me too
but in this round i can't carve out any
room for h2o to compete
2018's halloween wins by a landslide and
is up 2 to nothing
if h2o wants to avoid a blowout loss
it'll have to bring some serious wood to
the next round
happy halloween michael round three
storyline
yes h2o is in a big hole but maybe all
it needs to get back in the contest is a
change of scenery
how about sunny southern california
laurie strode cranked up the zeppelin
and moved out west with an aching in her
heart and the goal of making a fresh
start
she even changed her name to carrie tate
and has a son
john hey look everyone that's josh
hartnett
just sam the biggest differences between
this movie and its opponent is that h2o
continues the storyline from halloween
two that laurie
excuse me carrie and michael myers are
siblings
that strode girl that's michael meyer's
sister
perhaps it's that bond that won't allow
the sister to ever fully accept that her
brother is no longer a threat
when we meet her she's in the throes of
dysfunction manifesting itself in
alcoholism and horrific nightmares
luckily her kid seems to be a
stabilizing force in her life but he's
getting older and is about to fly the
nest
oh and um he might do the nasty on
halloween
with michelle williams did y'all not see
screw i know you saw screw she's
watching scream two
in the movie observe the rules of
sequels
jesus christ you don't know the rules i
have an aneurysm why don't you
worry isn't related to mikey in the
rebooted halloween 2018
but nonetheless he's an ever-present
force in her mind
even as she knows he's locked up in a
maximum security facility
she has dedicated her life to preparing
for his inevitable escape
she has locks guns ammo a remote
location
and very little in the way of a
relationship with anyone
even her own daughter about the only
thing she didn't count on
podcasters uh podcasters
whereas most pod folks sit in a comfy
studio and talk about politics
sports or why rotten tomatoes is wrong
these two yokels decide to confront the
ultimate center on their true crime
podcast
and they tease michael with his mask
very ill-advised
on today's show we reawaken the scariest
shape the world has ever seen
but first are you tired of going to the
post office use promo code [ __ ] at
stamps.com
once michael either completes his
cross-country trip or escapes his
institution
murder and mayhem ensue both flicks
feature a number of gruesome kills and
culminate with a showdown worthy of the
rising action we just witnessed
this round really comes down to laurie
we know the quantity of michael and the
various sharp objects he brings to the
table
laurie is such a cool badass in 2018's
halloween
she's cold alone and has been in this
life for so long
she's almost forgotten how to be a
regular human
she's the elder states woman of quote
final girls
and as such we'll stop at nothing to end
michael's reign of terror once and for
all
even if it costs her everything it's
fair to call this version of vlari the
most formidable foe of michael's career
but it's also a decidedly
one-dimensional lady strode
in comparison to the woman we meet in
h2o
i'm twice divorced and i'm a basket case
perhaps that laurie would have morphed
into the 2018 version
20 years later but even in her
functioning alcoholic state
we all still somehow have hope that this
year halloween
could be the one where she'll get back
to enjoying the family
she hasn't estranged yet and who knows
maybe even you get to hook up with a
colleague
i find laurie carrie i'm gonna call her
slash much more complex and interesting
in h2o and this coming from a guy who
loves action movies starring one note
heroes
worry somehow has more to lose in 1998's
film
her son her career and what remains of
her sanity
2018 laurie certainly didn't pick this
life for herself but she's made a
solitary piece with what has become of
her existence and the constant
preparedness that she's dedicated her
life to
the sibling relationship between laurie
and michael combined with the stakes for
herself and loved ones are the main
reasons why i give the nod in this round
to halloween 20 2018 gave us a great
reason to come back to the franchise
but in not ignoring everything that
happened after the ending of 1978's
halloween
h2o gave us a deeper more interesting
storyline
and it cuts the lead to two to one hey
it's halloween i guess everyone is
entitled to one good scare
i've had my share and now it's time for
the wild card round
iconic moments you think laurie had it
tough prepping for mike's impending
return
try deciding on one wild card round to
figure out this battle
i could have gone with better cast or
cooler kills or better michael myers
mask
but we go to see the movies because of
the moments that scare us at the time
and then continue to freak us out long
after the lights have gone back up
h2o doesn't waste any time in reminding
us who this
meyers fella is he's there from the
get-go murdering neighbors and closing
the loop on joseph gordon-levitt's
character
oh [ __ ] no [ __ ] if that gets us in the
mood
the tone is set as we experience a
nightmare alongside jamie lee curtis
oh speaking of her there's a really cool
cameo from her real-life mom
janet lee it's the perfect balance of
fan service
without completely halting the story if
i could be maternal for a moment
i'm also going to give a big shout out
to ll cool j security guard
he's a much welcome breath of fresh air
and if you want an iconic moment from
him
he survives
halloween from 2018 played more directly
on our fondness for the original
the opening credits give us john
carpenter's vintage theme
and the imagery of a jack-o-lantern
healing itself
talk about a great pumpkin charlie brown
say something
as bone-headed as it was to toss
michael's mask in front of him and
awaken the beast
it is a chilling moment i also enjoy our
introduction to laurie the superhero
and the awkwardness at a restaurant from
everyone who's doing their very best to
just get through the evening without a
full-blown dysfunctional family
embarrassment
that's good stuff we can all relate to
hey mom
that's mine i thought you quit drinking
but what this round comes down to is
laurie strode doing what she reluctantly
does best
taking on her brother or some dude
depending on which version you prefer
i appreciate 2018's incorporation of the
family dynamic taking hold
and mother and daughter working together
to trap michael in the basement
lots of cool nods to the original
surface during this climactic clash
including a disappearing body on the
lawn but the most iconic moment for me
comes as laurie locks her nemesis
a super rat finally caught in a maze
from which he cannot escape
in the basement it's not a cage baby
it's a trap as the flames blaze around
them both
it's a stirring moment where laurie's
training pays off
she went god mode and sent michael back
to hell
or at least until the next movie
[Music]
and while we know that version of warri
is capable of doing such things
in halloween 20 it's seeing a victim
who's been suffering at the hands of
this specter for two decades
finally become the aggressor the moment
where she safely ushers her son and
girlfriend out of harm's way
then fights every instinct in her body
and
in the audience by locking herself into
the compound where michael myers remains
is such a rush it's laurie saying
goodbye to her coping mechanism she's
relied on to get through the last 20
years
win or lose it's ending tonight where's
my axe
h2o wins this round based on that and
the icing on the cake is the between the
glass
shot of laurie and michael it's the
closest they're ever getting to a proper
family reunion
and maybe even michael realizes he's met
his match in that moment
just like me and my big sis every
christmas
halloween 20 wins the round and suddenly
we're tied at two wins apiece
overall i really enjoyed revisiting both
films in the halloween mythology
between the two of them they feature
some of the best moments most dastardly
kills
and scream out loud even though i'm
alone and it'll wake the dog scares
but now i have to decide between these
two i'm the tiebreaker a role that i'm
picking up with the same fervor that
laurie strode used when she grabbed that
axe in h2o
lock the gate alex he's the one of the
crew because this match is going to the
underdog cinderella story
1998's halloween 20 years later
[Music]
look i had a blast with 2018's halloween
and i cannot wait for halloween kills
next year
but in this modern world of constant
rebooting and do-overs and extended cuts
it feels like that film had an easier
hill to climb than the mountain of
here we go again eye rolling that h2o
might have been met with
although i'd say the reboot quilt
premise was the right way to go some 40
years later
i had to temper my enthusiasm for that
film with the acknowledgement
that we got some very convenient breaks
h2o shows us a more vulnerable
fully fleshed out lorry and thus her
mountain to climb
resembles that of the film itself to
earn credibility
both did hit their respective summit and
this halloween i'd encourage everyone to
go check out
halloween three season of the witch it's
got nothing to do with michael myers
get a fresh eye on it on october 31st
find it on fandango now is it on fanbank
i have no idea
just close your eyes and pick one
they're all good movies to scare ya they
get the job done
honey don't get too close
speaking of time for me to punch out and
you dear viewer are tasked with joining
the fray
vote for your favorite of the bunch in
the comments below and defend your
answer
as for me time to run home and start
putting up the christmas lights
you may think it's too early but have
you ever seen michael myers hurt anyone
during the season of giving
nope he's hibernating all you kids out
there that want halloween treats
enjoy your candy canes now get off my
lawn
[Music]
you